[Musica]
[Applauso]
si crede che viaggiare sia un movimento
del corpo un trasporto di ossa e carne
attraverso chilometri attraverso terra
mare cielo si crede che viaggiare se a
un piacere o una fatica un diritto o una
violazione e in mille modi per spostarsi
sulle ruote o sulle ali di un aereo sono
fatti per dimenticarsi che insieme al
corpo si muovono anche i sogni il
desiderio di giustizia di pace
e c'è chi fugge da prigioni da porte
chiuse da diritti negati a volte
all'inizio del viaggio ci sono dolori e
paura a volte all'inizio del viaggio
c'è una fuga una corsa senza fiato
lasciasse alle spalle l'ingiustizia la
libertà negata perché sei donna perché
fai parte di una minoranza a volte
all'inizio del viaggio ci può essere una
guerra
l'orrore la morte e non si può che
fuggire come se fuggirebbe da una bestia
feroce una corsa che consuma tutto il
fiato e dentro quella corsa dove non
potevo che fuggire non avevo più memoria
né idea di futuro
sono salita su una barca senza sapere la
sua destinazione alle mie spalle la
forza della mia ribellione e davanti a
me
la speranza il desiderio di dare forma
alla parola bellezza bocca già oggi ha
rubato la fed
il nostro è un teatro che ci piace
definire e che sceglie di essere
responsabile la responsabilità la
consapevolezza di servirsi del teatro
per dire cose importanti e urgenti
un teatro che fa drammaturgia con le
visioni poetiche dei matti con i disagi
con i razzismi con le discriminazioni
con i racconti delle donne dal 2003
portiamo avanti un progetto teatrale la
nave da meno per si chiama rivolto alle
donne native e migranti rifugiati e
profughi donne che non si rassegnano più
ad aspettare uomini dispersi nel mondo
alla ricerca di fortuna ma moderne
penelopi lasciano la casa di ulisse e si
mettono in viaggio a volte fuggono
arrivano desiderose di fare da questi
presupposti nascono i nostri progetti
teatrali attraverso il teatro ci si
allena a mettersi in gioco rompendo
schemi e resistenze senza giudizi senza
competizione è un po come fare un
viaggio ci siamo incontrate abbiamo
condiviso esperienze atmosfere storie
vissute o immaginate abbiamo condiviso
il progetto teatrale le diverse culture
abbiamo ascoltato con grande piacere le
diverse lingue e le diverse storie
sviluppando una sensibilità all'ascolto
per poi arrivare all'incontro al dialogo
alla contaminazione alla trasformazione
abbiamo cercato di creare uno spazio di
complicità che permetta a tutte anche
alle più restie di portare a galla le
espressioni della propria teatralità di
esprimere le proprie idee
esiste un argomento si costituisce un
progetto artistico poetico come un
ingegnere progetto un ponte dalle arcate
impossibili si crea un'atmosfera
protetta in cui ognuno semina si
ascoltano le parole le storie delle
donne
si scrive la drammaturgia questa
sequenza così facile da annunciare
e lunga pericolosa difficile ha bisogno
di duro lavoro di disponibilità e
soprattutto di poesia sul territorio
potersi smarrire per essere altrove per
essere se stesse o altre per essere
lontane o vicine per essere libere il
progetto artistico e il percorso
drammaturgico e narrativo non sono
sempre lineari e scorrevoli sono fatti
anche di intoppi e di conflitti
conflitti dove vengono scontri incontri
che si trasformano poi quasi sempre in
materiale vivo vero diventano altro
dapprima a volte credo che il conflitto
sempre se paritario sia necessario per
un accostamento un avvicinamento delle
diverse culture
ma il mio fare teatro è fatto non solo
di parole ma anche soprattutto di corpi
corpi che parlano che raccontano corpi
come atlanti e luoghi che includono il
loro vissuto e le loro relazioni corpi
persone donne donne spesso straordinarie
dove ognuna nasconde un segreto
un enigma un mistero nasconde bellezza
il mio lavoro è quello di rendere tutto
questo più percepibile e visibile sulla
scena mi viene in mente il primo
progetto teatrale rivolto alle donne
migranti e native era il 2003 voci
invisibili fanny ci raccontava una festa
tradizionale peruviana il suo racconto
era fatto di strade piazze grandi piene
di gente folle che vende invadevano la
strada tanti dolci lei era seduta su un
piccolo sgabello con il suo corpo minuto
aveva anche una caviglia ingessata che
la rendeva ancora più
fragile la contraddizione del suo
racconto così grande e il suo corpo così
piccolo era emozionante le cose piccole
diventano grandi e allora lavoro sulle
differenze sulla diversità dei loro
corpi dei loro sguardi lavoro per
mettere in scena i contrasti la loro
diversità come metafora di una comunità
capace di dare risposte di mettersi in
cammino verso una società che non teme
la pluralità attraverso il teatro
siamo uscite dai pregiudizi che spesso
gli altri ci impongono attraverso il
teatro la narrazione c'è una possibilità
di riscatto si creano e si amplificano
spazi ed occasioni per proporre un modo
diverso di fare democrazia in una
società sempre più chiusa uno spazio di
libertà
le storie delle donne sono anche passate
attraverso quella faticosa ea volta
conflittuale ridefinizione di un
identità femminile che si colloca fra
due diverse culture quella d'origine e
quella in cui si vive e spesso ti fa
sentire straniera la cultura è in
continua evoluzione
gli individui sono in continuo mutamento
il nostro tentativo è quello di andare
avanti non di tornare indietro
vogliamo aprirci il gruppo di lavoro un
gruppo aperto di solito sempre numeroso
numeroso proprio perché aperto le porte
sono aperte
tutti tutte insieme attorno ad un
progetto non importa la religione l'età
il colore della pelle
tutte insieme lavoriamo intorno ad un
progetto comune e per un po giochiamo
insieme a fare teatro il teatro è vita e
noi offriamo una visione laica dello
stare insieme
ci aiuta ci aiuta a comprendere meglio
un mondo che spesso non riconosciamo
indica quale direzione sta prendendo
l'umanità può fare da guida e aiutare a
non sbagliare strada con attenzione e
rispetto nei confronti dei mutamenti
sociali e culturali in atto
dobbiamo imparare a coabitare questa è
la sfida del terzo millennio e noi ci
proviamo e attraverso il teatro
abbiamo la possibilità di creare legami
relazioni di incontrare e ascoltare
l'altro a mille sguardi il teatro deve
guardare tutti i punti di vista e
accoglierli non è mia la città che fu di
mio padre non è mio il suo fare il suo
modo di pensare
eppure tanto li assomiglio non è mia la
città di mia madre
il suo tacere il silenzio che evoca
mille parole
ma da lei prendo la mia storia
io sono nuova nata qui dai genitori
considerati stranieri
io sono di questa terra la vostra la mia
il compito creo e ricordarvi che io sono
il futuro il futuro che non si cancella
io con il mio corpo
la mia pelle la mia voce che al suono di
1.000 agenti
io sono il futuro e il mio diritto di
essere cittadina non può essere negato
e se comunque a me respinge rete tornano
con altri corpi altre voci e facce e
canti e sodi io sono il futuro
nessuno mi può fermare il teatro si
occupa delle persone le rende
consapevoli e allo stesso tempo positive
nelle relazioni con gli altri
tutto questo non può che essere positivo
quasi un esercizio di cittadinanza nel
mio lavoro il teatro e la vita si
contaminano la scena uno spazio vivo
dove tutti tentano di essere veri il
nostro teatro coinvolge le persone quasi
mai attori di professione i nostri
progetti offrono occasioni di
partecipazione spazi attivi di
convivenza per cercare nuove possibilità
di comunicazione in un epoca in cui si
pensa che tutto debba rimanere fermo
immobile tutto si debba chiudere l'arte
diventa quasi un fatto politico
non dobbiamo avere paura del confronto
siamo chiamati a grandi cose aprirci a
cogliere capire il teatro è un
impalcatura invisibile è indispensabile
per cercare di comprendere la nostra
esistenza e per avere uno sguardo
diverso sul mondo per eliminare i
confini per ascoltare nuove parole uno
spazio in cui ancora possibile la
meraviglia
la scoperta la curiosità all'incontro
con gli altri vorremmo contribuire a
colmare la distanza tra la realtà in cui
viviamo e la nostra capacità di
comprendere una società in rapida
transizione sempre più plurale
cosmopolita vorremmo capirne le logiche
le nuove forme sociali di costume di
concezione culturale nel tentativo di
raggiungere una rinnovata consapevolezza
civile che attribuisca valore alle
differenze
abbiamo riflettuto sulle parole apertura
chiusura movimento libertà razzismo
cambiamento identità paura
responsabilità ricercando nel loro
significato forme tangibili di
convivenza e dialogo
tutto questo in un momento in cui si
fanno leggi per la sicurezza
dimenticando la libertà dell'essere
umano
e che basta nascondere agli occhi se
crede che basti recludere isolare si
fanno leggi per la sicurezza
dimenticando la libertà dell'essere
umano
se crede di sapere ciò che è bene e dove
comincia e finisce il male una
presunzione si fanno leggi per la
sicurezza ma la sicurezza di chi chi ha
diritto all incolumità e che no
che cosa vuol dire ha dunque sicurezza
che valore ha per chi senza più
documenti senza più dignità con l'anima
e il corpo violentati non ha più voce
nemmeno per chiedere aiuto
la cultura il diritto alla cultura
il diritto alla bellezza per tutti anche
per quelli che devono pensare per la
maggior parte del loro tempo ai bisogni
primari tra i bisogni primari ci devono
essere anche la cultura e l'arte non
solo da fruire ma anche da partecipare
la cultura deve essere democratica deve
raggiungere tutti l'arte è il teatro
sono dappertutto e dappertutto con
responsabilità la si può portare grazie
[Applauso]